this year biscuit is brought to you by
Squarespace the all-in-one platform that
makes it fast and easy to create your
own professional website e is the east
eyelet on the end website yes or online
portfolio for a free trial and 10% off
your first purchase go to
squarespace.com and use our offer code
R&L that's our a and DL okay you need a
website you need to use Squarespace it's
you know you know the drill
it's they make it easy and listen how
much do you think it cost I can say
$1,000 a month $8 a month
Oh a lot lower than I thought includes a
free domain name if you sign up for a
year so the only problem I see is not
the price that that's the solution $8 a
month the problem is coming up with a
domain name so I mean that's something
that that's not easy but that's the
point everybody has a website and you
need to get on this train well the
domain name thing is is quite a chore I
remember one time we started trying to
come up with some way to come up with a
website that would point to
rhettandlink.com/store whatever like
that would ever happen to having a
couple of times so we came up with
Internet peanut butter calm which I
think still works oh yeah it does but
that if that's any indication of how
hard it is to come up with a domain name
that's the thing that you've got to do
don't delay yeah just go ahead and
reserve that but you get to do it for
free and then eight dollars a month
that's like a latte and a half depending
on the size that you get and where you
get the latte from you said are you
you're doing like a conversion and
coffee conversion like the charity like
this is not a charity like for the cost
of a latte and a half you can come you
can contribute to the charity if you
want to use that voice to get people to
sign up for Squarespace I don't care
start a trial with no credit card
required you could make a charity
website I start building your website
today when you decide to sign up for
Squarespace charity website com
make sure that's I'm sure that's take
you don't get their hopes up make sure
to use your offer code R and L that's RA
and DL to get tempers
off your first purchase and to show your
support for ear biscuit I really don't
like it when you talk like that kind of
makes me feel uncomfortable it but you
want to give to charity yeah I do but I
want them to sign up for Squarespace so
they can show their support of ear
business let's make another ear biscuit
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link it's time for another
conversation with someone interesting
from the internet this week that person
is Michael Gallagher the man behind the
YouTube channel totally sketch it's
currently one of the most sought-after
directors on YouTube plus he made waves
as the first youtuber to score a
theatrical release of his debut feature
length film smiley we discussed his
beginning a directing career at the age
of 14 by convincing the actors that he
was 30 we also talked about how he finds
the edge of what's acceptable for
content on YouTube and how his foam
smiley led to death threats for him and
his friends and family now it's
interesting because you know the smiley
is obviously a horror film and it's not
called the smiley it's just called this
for this film smiley is is a horror film
and you come right out until Michael and
art talk with him that you have no plans
on seeing it because you don't like
horror films yeah the trailer was scary
enough to convince me that this is not
my cup of tea and I you know I think
we've established this you know in our
previous air biscuit discussion we
started that your mom indoctrinated you
to appreciate horror films as a shared
experience at a young age I mean we
talked about the detail I think that
might be a little bit of a misconception
okay but you I will say that you tried
to indoctrinate me my mom likes horror
movies because of this her personality
type is similar in the in that way and I
like him for the same reason she didn't
want my brother didn't watch him Oh wear
this it's me and her hmm
I think he'll watch a horror movie but
yeah so it was just something that it's
the same thing and interestingly enough
I usually describe it like a thrill ride
you know I like to ride
roller coasters at an amusement park you
like to ride roller coasters at
amusement park there now I'll tell you
the reason I like to ride a roller
coaster is because my what is happening
to my body is telling my mind that I am
going to die my mind believes that
there's no way a human can be thrown in
these positions have these g-forces put
onto their body without them being an
imminent danger right and so Anthony but
you know you know what I'm not gonna die
maybe somebody died one time on Space
Mountain but I'm not gonna die so I get
the same exact sensation when I watch a
horror movie I think I could be the one
being killed now I might be about to die
but I know that I'm not really going to
so it's just in the exact same way so I
want to know what is the difference
III do enjoy rollercoasters I don't I
didn't know that it was like a fear of
death but maybe it is it's just being
scared it's not that I don't like being
scared it's just I just think it's
demented and gross and it gets puts
nasty thoughts into my mind that all
right so that's what I mean by scary as
in like nasty and demented but okay so
if right now that door busted open in a
black bear well on us a grizzly bear one
that could actually do some damage and
came in here and all of a sudden we were
like oh crap and we ran out this door
and then we ran for like 200 yards is
this huge bear chased us and then we got
up on top of a house and got away from
him somehow I'd be like this is awesome
exactly right you almost died but you
didn't die I'm the bear was like a demon
demon bear and his entrails were hanging
out and he was like murdering people and
like that just makes it better I mean
like a gross way I'd be like oh that
bear is gross man but okay now I don't
want to see this bear we also talked on
a previous year biscuit about how on my
birthday in 2013 that my what I wanted
to do for my birthday party was have
yeah last October my guy friend
come to the studio and watch in this
room actually because there's no windows
and it's kind of soundproof we set up
the we set up to every to watch the
conjuring which is you know a lot of
people consider to be one of the
scariest movies of all time definitely
the scariest movie I've ever seen
because I don't watch a lot of scary
movies because you don't like to watch
oh my wife doesn't like to watch so but
you can't I looked at you while we were
watching that and you just you were
scared out of your mind so was i it's
not that I'm not scared you seemed like
you were having the great time though
whether it wasn't I guess it was a
little demented or maybe it got a lot
demented but it didn't get gross it
wasn't good you don't like gory I don't
like okay so that helped a little bit
but for days leading up to it I made up
my mind I'm gonna support you and your
birthday wish and I'm gonna be here for
you and I'm I psyched myself up to
everything you're talking about I'm
gonna overcome this I'm gonna have a
good time I'm not gonna hate this I'm
gonna enjoy it and I did and I actually
felt even better because our friend Tony
who was also here he was worse off than
than I was and in terms of hating these
type of movies so his earbuds in well he
goes upstairs and he's like leaving
during the movie and stuff like that and
he he comes down and he hasn't put in
earbuds he's borrowed the headphones off
of your desk yeah and he's wearing he's
watching the movie to support you and
your desire to have fun in this way on
you're listening the iTunes he's
listening to happy music
yeah and in kind of looking at the
screen with one eye like if you're
listening to like you know like Beyonce
it's not gonna be that scary while
you're watching this movie but okay with
it and that made me feel better but this
is so I mean I'm a box he appreciated it
because you didn't Punk out Tony punked
out you didn't Punk out but and I didn't
I agree yeah I don't and I did have fun
I don't I haven't seen the Saul series I
don't I don't care about that kind of
stuff yeah you said demented and gross
yeah I like the ring I like the
conjuring I like these movies that have
this psychological thriller like
supernatural supernatural supernatural
it's totally crazy freak you out right
but this isn't this is my thing this is
what I want to say to you that I think
that this is like spicy food
in and but you have in this past year or
so you know yeah I kind of I kind of get
it you'll eat something spicy but I kind
of get why this is good I think that you
could we could be like horror movie
going buddies you know we could just
like hey man let's go let's go watch a
horror movie just to just to us you
gotta learn how to say the word horror
horror watch a horror movie and and this
could be like a shared experience
because I enjoy them so much or maybe we
could just get somebody to come in here
and threaten us like weakly well it
would be a less of a time commitment you
know just an actor get an actor with a
mask well if it's a psychological
supernatural threat I'm okay with that
but if it's like a adjacent smiley kind
of threat like that kind of thing let's
get like a demon-possessed little girl
to come in once a week scare the living
crap out of us like every Friday at 4
o'clock she's got those little girls
gonna come in we start with you're gonna
float in can we start with a
demon-possessed like grown woman and we
need to work down to a little girl
because the younger they get this crypto
Maura carry-all Wow
mmm I can't demon baby is as bad as it
gets
has that movie been made yeah it was it
was that viral it he had a baby devil
baby or some like that demon baby
okay so that's what Michael has done he
has he is he's made a movie because I
was back in 2012 and you know it's been
out but he's he's done this as a
youtuber yeah he actually pulled it off
he made a horror movie and you know he's
his YouTube channel continues to go
strong totally sketch has over 1 million
subscribers over 400 million views he
also does a lot of other directing for
other people at Reggie Watts he directed
Reggie Watts
reg world video also directed Joey
Graceffa dramatic series that came out
late last year storytellers among many
others and he's worked with Shane Dawson
jenna Marbles to return a Kassem G to
name a few but less
get into it alright here's our ear
biscuit with Michael Gallagher okay so
you just watched wolf of Wall Street so
you enjoyed that but I know you're a fan
of Dumb and Dumber are you excited about
Dumb and Dumber to I have to say I'm so
excited that I am sort of I'm saying I'm
not so sure it's gonna be good cuz I
don't want to get my expectations so
skyrocketing high that when I see the
film it can't possibly live up to those
expectations because I really want to
enjoy the movie well what kind of place
is dumb and Dumberer holding your heart
I mean is it a special locale in there
yeah oh yeah I've seen it like probably
a hundred times I mean it's one of those
movies that could my parents were really
into comedy so growing up they would
like all our VHS tapes were comedies
you know like Michael Keaton movies okay
you know Jim Carrey like the mask Dumb
and Dumber
Ace Ventura even the sequel Ventura to
where he's in Africa oh yeah it's
incredible he does this whole monopoly
guy but it's and I recommend you check
it out if you haven't seen it but you're
not a Jim Carrey fan you're a Dumb and
Dumber fan about movie I'm but but yeah
where do you guys get $10 from where did
you research it my mom yeah no minion
yeah we have minions we just have time
the person who helped us find out that
information is listening and we just
called her a minion I don't think that's
gonna go over she's the one that just
took a picture of us she's lovely yeah
she made this really lovely papaya tea
she did tastes exactly like so why dumb
and Dumberer though specifically I mean
it sure it's a great movie but why latch
onto that one I think there's just
something about like joyous like dumb
just going to the baseline of being so
dumb that I don't know like everything's
numb like that's just how reality is
there's something about that level where
they're just everything they're saying
like they don't even realize that the
next thing they're saying doesn't make
sense to the last thing like they're
constantly contradicting themselves or
something so when you're that dumb it's
just it's bliss
it's perfect so and no film has ever
captured it since I don't think well you
know the interesting thing about Jeff
Daniels and Jim Carrey too is that I was
just looking at an article about the
movie and you made this observation Jim
Carrey hasn't aged well Jeff Daniels
looks exactly the same like it like I
mean he his hair is a little bit
different but I'm I think it's gonna
look like like a father and son that's
what I'm worried about
I really think it's gonna come across
like a father and son because Jim
Carrey's I think Jeff Daniels has done a
little injections or somehow you think
it's maintained the smoothness well
whoever as doctors is good yeah right
he's not with like meg Ryan current-day
if you've seen Mariah who's she's got
puffy lips yes really
they're marshmallows they're big but
it's been overdone yeah a little bit but
no yeah he looks like a baby he's a baby
I don't know what a secret is
so do you channel any of that
inspiration into totally sketch like is
there a direct connection there well
it's funny cuz I think it's it's not
just Dumb and Dumber actually it's that
like the Farrelly Brothers early movies
okay I think I really dug I think those
movies are I mean some of the best like
between you know kingpin Dumb and Dumber
and there's something about Mary it's
like the Holy Trinity those are the best
of their comedies I think but I don't
know they just they sort of took what
like the Zucker Brothers did like the
airplane like that kind of you know
sporadic like so many jokes like joke a
minute thing and they also gave it heart
and they actually cared so by the end of
the movie were still paying attention
you wanted to know how it ended and
there was a little bit of suspense so I
think that there's something about that
kind of combination of just you know
kind of going for it and then it's also
that sort of inappropriate humor that
like we're crossing the line we're going
into a zone where you know you almost
make the audience feel a little
uncomfortable for a minute and okay get
to the joke I think there's something
about that that was really exciting to
me because I like being like I was very
young when I saw a lot of these movies
that I probably shouldn't have and so
there is something like I think the fear
of oh my parents gonna like stop playing
the tape or at some point are they gonna
say I gotta leave the room or close my
eyes or something I'll be exciting about
that why don't I am with
yeah I had to watch it with my parents
my think I should be watching this right
now right and then it's like but we're
still watching it so keep it going guys
I'm not gonna make eye contact with the
parents right now yeah it's like when
you're watching you know there's so I
saw there's something about Mary in the
theater with my parents and you know I'm
25 now so when that movie came out I was
I was less I was like 13
12 13 and it was a little too young for
me to see that movie I mean you know
there's I don't want to say all the
things that are in that movie but
they're very lair jealousy and you know
we didn't leave let's just say that we
did not leave the theater I saw the
entire film and I saw in the theater
where the house was packed and everyone
was roaring with laughter like literally
the room was shaking it was that like
it was one of the few times I've seen a
movie where everyone is laughing at
every joke and it's just like so loud
you're not even hearing the next line so
I think something about that like those
early experiences they made me you know
understand the power of comedy and it's
interesting because I can I guess I can
imagine like a younger kid looking at
your channel and maybe having that same
kind of experience now say I'm gonna
click on this video interactive sex he's
got a hundred million views it must be
good hope mom doesn't walk in yeah they
got the butterflies I got their door
that they have to keep open their depth
at one eye on the door and then they got
one eye on the video so they watching
with their parents baby on their lap
weird hey mom check this out yeah
different different strokes for
different folks no pun intended so I
mean I have to imagine there's some
calculation and kind of working the
whole internet video thing in your favor
with the sexual subject matter and just
kind of flirting with okay what's gonna
be beyond this click kind of a thing for
you yeah I think I you know I think when
you you kind of push the envelope with
sensors and YouTube doesn't really have
like there's no CEO MPAA or there's no
like real sensor board you just sort
have to like it's sort of the buddy
system like this yeah Boy Scout system
of we're gonna put something out here
and it might get flagged might not it's
sort of you know communal you never know
it's gonna go down and so I kind of like
the idea of toying with that invisible
line and sometimes I've crossed it for
sure and then other times I've been
right up to it and I think that you know
that's interesting cuz a lot of people
you know make things that are very safe
and you know and that's fine but I like
you know kind of putting the edge in
there so that way you never know what
you're gonna see next there's no tension
to it
have you been flagged have you been
knocking down yes a million tab no no
not a million times I you know I
probably have like you know ten flagged
videos way to hundreds when your flag 10
out of 200 videos they they're taken
down automatically unless you can prove
they should go back up right and so most
of them have gotten proven that you
should go back up like like what what
would be taken down and then you can say
well this is how I danced this line give
me a specific example well you know it's
it's weird cuz YouTube isn't that like
not very vocal like I don't have like a
guy at YouTube that I call and he's my
guy you know you know video gets for
like YouTube doesn't call you I don't
get a call know right I just sort of
happens like I just see that nobody can
watch anymore oh no what's going on what
happened what I do and then so then I
have to go and kind of figure it out and
I'm like what was the video that got
flagged and walked me through with a
specific example this is one video
called I think it's like the low-cut
shirt I think that's what I look at
shirt you familiar with the the I've
seen the thumbnail yeah no so that video
you know it's basically about a girl who
wears an extremely low-cut shirt out on
a dinner date and the guy as being a guy
takes a peek at her cleavage and while
while he's down there looking the the
sound gets muffled and he's just sort of
like focused in on it
and then all of a sudden she says
something and she's like you know Peter
did you hear what I just said and he's
like yeah of course and then she pulls
out a gun she's like did you really
because now you have to answer and then
becomes interactive where he has to
guess what she just said
and we as an audience have no idea what
she just said so it's a really
ridiculous
and he got flagged just because I think
cuz of the boobage cuz there was a high
level of boob boob activity Ben then how
did you get it unflagged I didn't have a
YouTube guy well the way things get
flagged from my understanding as you
know civilian that it's a certain
percentage if it's a high percentage of
people who are watching your video flag
it doesn't matter if it's you know just
like you know your nephew playing on
some steps or you know a girl like
taking off her clothes doesn't matter
what it is if like enough percentage if
I don't know if it's 10 percent or 15
percent it's automated its automated
yeah so if if your video just goes out
and maybe a few hundred people have seen
in her a thousand people have seen it
and a high number of them have clicked
flag then it could go down but I didn't
come back that's what happened so I had
to email them it took a day or so and
then they realized like oh you know you
didn't break any rules and and when it
goes up to is it then you have to sign
in is because I because I noticed a few
of your videos you have to sign in you
have to verify your age there's a few of
them that yeah like you can you can
still have it up once it's been flagged
but you have to go through like an age
gate thing and I don't think there's ads
on them or anything like that so it's
like a weird part of YouTube where it's
like 18 and older Club like big flashy
oh you're ready brought back up that's
how the sign and thing happens no no so
some of them are you got you guys never
had a video flag I'm guessing ever
actually yes you have we did we we had
it's actually the interesting story
because it was the video that I think is
partially responsible for our popularity
on YouTube initially oh you mean the
pornographic one we really see a video
of my son a video of my son he was 3
years old at the time he was crying
about a NC State
UNC game that's where we're from North
Carolina and my wife and I filmed our
son and we put it on our channel he was
distraught about the Wolfpack losing to
the target yes right and he was just so
distraught and it was hilarious but he
just so happened to be in his underoos
yeah he was just a three-year-old in his
like tighty whiteys or whatever and that
got flagged well it got taken down twice
on my personal channel which I don't
have anymore
whoa and then I was like I'm putting
this up on
our channel if then YouTube contacted us
and said contacted you and said we want
to feature this video on the homepage
because everyone's talking about it is
hilarious but it's but it's been taken
down so well we didn't take it down is
what she said and so you explained it to
him and then you re uploaded it and we
may had a conversation should we we
should reapplied it to the rhett and
Link channel because we were just trying
to get started on his personal change
foot like we put a watermark at
rhettandlink.com/store antigen this
thing if YouTube's gonna feature it so
it went from being flagged and taken
down to being featured by YouTube who
asked to have a foot backup that's
incredible so that just goes to show you
the state of YouTube at the time
underdog story that's like an inspiring
film right so a slightly different
approach but yeah our content is
different so we haven't been we haven't
experienced the flagging gotcha
you know we don't typically shoot kids
in their underwear and put it on our
shame that's true good that's good I
appreciate that as an American right
thank you
but I mean okay so yeah so we've worked
with some naked Russian man I've been
supposedly naked but I think that's a
there's a little bit of a contrast there
because if somebody's gonna be naked in
one of our videos there's a good chance
that it's gonna be one of us you made
kind of a decision early on to be to say
you know what I'm gonna approach this
YouTube thing a little bit differently
than everyone else was approaching it
you you were going to be the creative
force behind it but not necessarily be
the face of it right so how did that
happen yeah I think I wanted well my
initial idea was to do try and do like
an SNL type show where it was you know I
could just create it and you know like
Lorne Michaels comes out every once in a
while at SNL you know he's the guy
behind it but you know he'll do some
funny like stuff as himself but he
doesn't really play characters he's not
really an actor and he doesn't pretend
to be either yeah he just likes funny
people and you know puts them together
and kind of keeps that show going it's
more producer director guy and so I
thought oh I could do that on YouTube in
a small sort of way I could do one a
week to a week you know sketches and you
know I could pay for myself and get
funny actors and things and and I just
always approached everything I did as a
writer director
producer cuz that's always what I wanted
to do but you know making a feature film
it cost so much money and so much time
it's so many people and great script and
so there were so many things in the way
of blocking for me to make feature films
at that time that's when I started I
think I was 19 or 20 or not so I was
what yeah yeah it was 20 so well where
was the filmmaker spark ignited when did
that happen
I think what happened was I think at an
early age my parents like loved movies
love comedies and I got to see them all
like that was the communal thing like
we'd always you know my parents both
worked and so when when we did spend
time together at nights weekends and
like they were great parents we would
watch movies we would go to movies you
know we'd see comedy shows like I
remember seeing Rodney Dangerfield when
I was like 10 years old really like
stuff that like whoa like why am I like
I knew I was something interesting going
on like I knew most kids weren't doing
that because I would like my parents
would you know like to go see comedy
show like in San Diego we had a lot of
good comics come through or okay you
know a couple times throughout my youth
we went to like Vegas and being a kid in
Vegas can't do anything except at night
somehow they got me into like comedy
shows or concerts or whatever the cool
stuff that it could do so I got to see
George Carlin before he died
12 and it's just like and then I'd go
back to school and be like acid George
Carlin over the weekend no kid George
Carlin was there I was just like this
weird kid and then so I actually had
older friends and when I had those older
friends at a young age I could then talk
to them about movies and comics and you
know what kind of the things that were
interesting to me and they exposed me to
more you know funny people and you know
like oh you got to listen to this and
like oh do you know who Steve Martin is
like oh not just from these movies but
like go listen there's little comedy
specials and you know read this book and
it was just like there's a lot of that
kind of information and education that I
got not from school but from just being
interested in films and comedy that
helped me you know just always be
interested so from a various issues I
was always kind of I was like this weird
only child who was listening to comedy
albums and yeah it's interesting I mean
I I mean most everyone's into some form
of entertainment but to have parents
really
state agent parents who seem to be both
passionate about comedy mm-hmm it seems
to be very interesting you know those
real estates they're horrible senses
fewer I don't know that of they weren't
like Glengarry Glen Ross real estate
agents you know they weren't like
cutthroat bloody you know whatever they
were I just don't have bus bench
you know ads they were like never like
the nice real estate yeah I think I
don't think that I just don't think that
I've ever met a couple like Oh their
thing is comedy yeah they're really into
comedy that's cool and they kind of
trained you up into that I mean for you
to be able to say you saw the greats who
are dead yeah and at the age of like 11
12 that's that's pretty cool yeah but
that takes kind of a special sensibility
from your parents that that must have
been kind of a thing for them they were
always the audience they were always
like the quintessential audience so I
don't know that was so much that they
were like they weren't like comedy snobs
they're not like know this kind of
companies better than this kind and I
you know I only listen to George Carlin
and like I would never like you know
whoever you know they like everybody
they like Jerry Seinfeld they like Frank
Caliendo they like anyone doesn't make
him laugh they're not snobbish about it
no but personality-wise were they were
obviously fans of comedy but was your
household one where they were cracking
jokes and you were cracking jokes a
little bit my parents were like the most
hilariously unintentional funny people
were ever like they would not try but
then they would acknowledge how like
ridiculous
something was I didn't mean to do that
but it was funny yeah well my dad was
pretty hilarious he was sorta like like
Joe Pesci a little bit like a Joe Pesci
Alec Baldwin type you know like you can
I was like an East Coast mob guy but
he's not he's saying it's like literally
no mob connections whatsoever but he
like I don't know all my friends were
like is your denim lovely yeah that's
like you wore rings and you know like
dark like olive skin and you know hair
slicked back and like drove a black like
sedan hey you want to buy his house yeah
that's the best I can do yes do want to
buy this house trust me
I kind of had that vibe and then he was
really clumsy yeah that look and then he
would like spill something on him he
would all here were really nice like
suits for real estate and then he was
spill something on it and he just curse
up a storm and then it's just my mom
which is laughs and then he was just
like you know I'm like Marlon Brando
meets Columbo that's what I'm picturing
that's not that it's not far off yeah
that's pretty much basic Columbo with a
stain on his shirt yeah my mom you know
she loves comedy and yes she was really
funny and you know she actually she told
me this recently when I was little you
know like they read like you know good
night moon and the bernstein bears and
like certain normal kid books she also
read me joke books like tons joke books
like just from a young age I think
wasn't so much for me it was more like
she knew she just had to read me
something so I go to sleep and so after
a while you run out of books she used to
start reading jokes and then so it would
like amuse her okay so she could like
stay up to actually read me something
cuz some of those kid books it's like
you know mr. bear goes dude pantry
what's in the paper tray Oh glass of
milk yeah right you know familiar with
your familiar oh yeah I've got a baby
you know what's going but you didn't
want to become a comedian you ended up
want to become a filmmaker so how did it
was you know you're watching the film so
that was your connection but first I've
thought I wanted to be a I recently
figured out that I wanted to be an
entertainer it's got really what I
wanted to be and that's still what I
want to do just directing is sort of the
form that I like the most and it's the
one that I'm most comfortable with I
think out of all the different ways you
can entertain somebody from magic to
being a comedian to an actor to you know
a novelist anything so the yeah being
being a kid I wanted to be an actor at
first I thought I did but it was really
I wanted to entertain people because I
liked the idea of making people laugh
and getting reaction like in school I
started telling jokes and started like
trying to be funny and and all that and
you know I had I had a good run as a
class clown in a few classes and you
know it was you know I always had an
entertaining group of friends we'd
always like you know we were like into
comedy growing up and
so it was a lot of that but then I think
the directing kind of came in when I
realized that being an actor was gonna
be such a nightmare because so many
other people want to be an actor and
that path seems so narrow and so like I
didn't know how to break in and this was
this was a young high school yeah at a
young age because my parent when I
wanted to be an actor my parents were
really supportive and actually took me
out and like got me some acting classes
for like kid actors and like I went on
some auditions they've enjoyed driving
up to LA and I went on 20 auditions or
something
and so I I did I made a noble effort as
a kid to try to be an actor
but like doing that process I would read
a commercial like I'd read the the sides
for a chapstick commercial and the lines
for the kid would be like my name's
Billy and I love cherry chapstick
because it put it on my lips and mm-hmm
good cherry chapstick it's just like
that's those are the words it's like I
can't do anything with those words man
like there's nothing like there's
nothing good that I could ever show you
what those were and it makes me want
chefs to it could mean to be honest with
you
but it was one of those things where I
would literally all like that and I just
started realizing like there's no point
in us doing this he's kind of like yeah
I had a group you know I had a chat with
my parents and it was just like you know
if this is what acting is this like this
isn't what I thought acting is and if
this is what acting is I don't think
this is what I want to do like I want to
entertain people and so then my parent
started talking like well you know
you're saying what someone else wrote
like this is what someone else has come
up with for their product or for
whatever it is you know if you want to
just entertain people you should try and
figure out ways to you know make make
your own stories and make your own
dialogue and things and so that started
putting in my head of like oh you should
make your own stuff yeah how does that
start well I think it started with just
you know I got a I got my dad's you know
old you know VHS digital camera I think
that I think we he had that one and then
I had the high eight camera shot high
eight and then I got the mini DV that
was that was my progression oh yeah
and basically it started with making
kind of like jackass style videos with
my friends where they would you know put
them in shopping carts and throw them
down a hill and I'd be on rollerblades
trying to like film them and catch funny
things and then you know some stuff
where I would you know it's like it's
like all the typical little kid movies
where you you know have your friends
dress up in suits and they wear
sunglasses and you have like little
orange guns and you're playing like
mobsters and you know someone's gotta
get the briefcase and and save save the
lady in the top of your parents house
like really ridiculous you know and this
is before it YouTube of oh yeah this is
you know this is 1990 no I I started MIT
started filming things like messing
around filming things I think in fourth
grade like I think what I've learned
pretty quick in school was that if I I
didn't have to do the essay I didn't
have to write a long essay or do a book
report I could actually just go film a
reenactment or make my own movie
interpretation so it started as just oh
I was making things not thinking of oh
I'm a director I'm like just making
stuff for school probably a ting at
creating and then and actually what the
real the real moment that I think I
switch to filmmaking and this is
sounding probably so boring anyone
listening who cares but I basically my
parents found out about this thing New
York Film Academy which they have them
all over the place now they had one in
LA at the time they just started less
confusing I know
it's basically like a subway have them
everywhere okay or McDonald's but yet so
New York Film Academy is basically like
a franchise like film school they
started in New York and then the next
one they brought out was to LA and then
now I think they haven't like Prague and
Paris and all kinds of cool places okay
but the one in LA was so cool because
they had to deal with universals backlot
or you could film on like some of their
sets like they had like New York Street
and they had like the jaws set and you
know whatever else that was available at
the time western town oh you know and
they would let you film there for your
project for as a student and it was like
oh my god this is incredible you were
how old at this time I was 14 I was 14
Wow and I said I got to go to this thing
and so I begged my parents and they they
let me go for a summer and I did a
six-week program there where you shoot
we shot 16 millimeter sync sound film oh
wow yeah old school old school so in the
end there was a choice there because
they had acting
gram and a film program and it was the
choice of which one do I want to go and
I realized then if I went into the
acting program I would not be able to
use the sets and I would be able to make
my own thing and who knows if I'll even
get cast in something you know just go
there and be doing vocal warm-ups and
read and learn how to read monologues
and then that's it and I said no you
know I'll learn directing and if I
really want to I'll cast myself if I
really want to and but I ended up not
casting myself because I'm not an actor
I'm more of like a I could do something
funny on camera maybe but it's more of
you know I just more of a guy guy yeah a
guy can talk so I mean you know this is
an opportunity that a lot of you know
not many 14-year olds have you know to
get this kind of training to get this
kind of support from your parents where
did that lead because you know you had
four more years of high school I guess
and you graduate and then not long after
that it's a couple years you're hey I'm
gonna do this YouTube thing what
happened in those ending high school you
know did you go to college like what
happened in that pathan period yes so
yeah what happened is like all
throughout high school so I I did the
New York Film Academy in between the
year a middle school to high school okay
in between those years in that summer
the six weeks I did this film came and
changed my life because I shot you know
some 16 millimeter short films
I cast sag actors as a 14 year old like
I literally like cold called actors and
put on a voice at 14 like hi I'm Michael
Gallagher from mgg productions how you
doing today
mister you know st. John yes we have a
role for you that we'd love to have you
come in for it'll be Sunday August 5th
or whatever it was and so I just like
had this like speech that I wrote down
and I just did a radio voice and called
actors and yeah and got people and I had
a crew and we were all like 14 and we
made short films these actors show up
and they're like ah kid where's the
director where's this guy tellem animal
am I talking like this I had a lot of
that yeah actually I had there's one
actor the first actor I've ever hired
his guy Billy st. John he's great he was
actually mr. deeds you know that Adam
Savage yeah he he was in this like
dinner scene where he's like with all
these like fancy New York socialites and
he writes for The New Yorker
and he's like you know they make fun of
him and then Adam Sandler beats the crap
out of him it's like policie so he had a
couple lines that Adams animu so I saw
his head shot and I was like I gotta get
this guy cuz I just saw mr. deeds ask
for tea you know like this is cool thing
ever and work with this guy and so I
called him up and somehow coaxed him to
come out and he was in my short film and
we and he thought literally it was until
years later cuz I'd cast him and
everything and he was like oh my god
like I thought you were I thought you
were like 30 years old just like a short
thin guy but he's the coolest guy uh and
I pretty much put him in everything I
ever do but so that period really
changed my life and so then when I went
back to high school it was like this
that I was like hooked it was like crack
I just smoked crack I'm hooked hard my
teeth are falling out I am making movies
like that was what I was gonna do so I
was a weird kid where you know when I
when we could do a you know a book
report on something I'd be like hey can
I do my book report on Sid fields book
about storytelling and screenwriting and
they'd be like sure and then I would
read a whole book about screenwriting
yeah knowing what you wanted to do and
as like a freshman in high school you
were to kind of gear your high school
experience toward your trajectory as a
filmmaker I treat my college yes I tried
to treat it as like colleges the most I
can't most I could because I I just I
just couldn't wait I was so antsy how
did that create so did you create like a
high school opus right no I well you
know it was like a ton of short projects
it's really what it was I didn't make
like a feature film through high school
that would've been cool it was always my
dream to do a feature film but I never
had I didn't have the right idea to do a
full feature and I couldn't sit still to
really write like a full 90 page film so
at that time it was just tons of shorts
music videos and then I you know I don't
know I just had this like you know
confidence encouraged where I felt like
I could get jobs like I have been to
film school
at the really film camp but I've been to
film school I you know I know enough
about film equipment and either you know
DP cuz I at the film school what's cool
is you switch off positions to everybody
in your class like going to film school
in a way where you get to DP someone
else's project and do sound gaff and you
know edit and do everything so you do
every position so I had a pretty good
understanding everything and so I just
applied that to everything I did making
short films so then I would submit my
short films to film festivals I got in
and then I would apply for directing
jobs I got some of them like I directed
a few commercials a few music videos
when I was 15 16 years old I did I did a
commercial that was a music video hybrid
commercial ad with the Bam sha-na-na who
played at Woodstock back in the day well
for the PT Cruiser for a local car
commercial sound familiar
yeah so I was Engle on that it was they
had a song called the cat and the PT
Cruiser and I did a music video with the
band sha na na and I got like a little
crappie crane I got paid a few thousand
dollars and it's like you know sixteen
and I you know direct-to-home UVI got my
friends to boom and do the whole thing
and edited on final cut which I had and
you know and then I did not know that
like nobody told me like oh like what
are the specs that you have to go out
for for TV like all the specific export
information or any of that so I just
kind of winged it and just acted like I
knew what was going I had no idea and it
aired local it aired in San Diego
commercial yep that's you remember
seeing it on TV I do it was very
exciting and then I remember getting
calls from like relatives about it and
because I would you know my mom would
write exactly make cameos and all of our
local commercials did you do that
because I didn't Hitchcock it now yeah I
would I should have you'd have more
relatives calling it would have been
weird for like were you in the back of
that PT Cruiser for a second
it was really all six year old dudes so
if it was like 150 year old boy with a
little beard maybe just let the fifteen
year old boy be the director was the
angle that the entire band can fit into
the PT Cruiser because it's kind
like a clown car I we literally had all
the bad members in the car of course
worse uh yeah no that was there was no
angle to the music video it was just
like you know I figured out I'd watched
enough music but at that point I was
like alright all we got to do is film
shayana for different locations and put
him in different positions I hope I got
ya I was so nervous going to that shoot
I actually remember because I remember
they had like for some reason it was
like a really big deal like they had
like press because Shauna hadn't done a
music video in like forever
they hadn't done anything in a long time
they'd just done like concerts and so
they had like press like the head like
news anchors and they like people on the
set like filming us film the thing and
then they did like new segments of it
and then wrote articles on it there's a
big deal I remember 15 I were getting to
set yeah I took the train up from San
Diego to go to LA cuz we did half the
video now I have in San Diego and I took
the train up and I had my xl2 in my case
and then I was with the buddy and I had
a you know tripod and literally that's
all we brought to this video cuz we were
doing an outdoor shoot and we were like
yeah well you know we'll bounce some
light and we'll figure it out like it
was so ghetto
I showed there's all these press people
and shot on the PAS here he has a tripod
camera so I literally I was like oh yeah
this is great guys excuse me for just
one moment and then I just went away and
I like went to the bathroom and I had to
like pep-talk myself as like a 16 year
old and then got the courage and threw
some water in my face went back out
there and said okay let's do this and
then I just started you know putting on
director mode kill it killed it boom
local TV commercial so that was that
like the high school highlight yeah I
wore that thing like a trophy I went
around not I should have and what from
there yeah so it was like a lot of that
kind of stuff in high school so then
from there I I went to LMU for one
semester I went for one semester and at
the same you know when I was going to
college my parents said you know we'll
help you out for a little bit but you
know you're really on your own here like
you got to pay for school you have to
pay for your living expenses everything
which is you know which is great I
actually I think because it made me say
I want to become financially independent
right now not because I want to but but
I actually they very much really have to
and what would you decide to study there
cuz you didn't decide to go to like USC
film school or something like that
oh I applied everywhere but no I did not
I didn't get into a lot of I got into
Chapman but I didn't get into their film
school it was very competitive at the
time okay so you were trying to get into
it tried to get into a film school yeah
it submitted to like NYU and USC I think
I don't think I submitted UCLA but yeah
I got into San I got into UC Santa Cruz
and then I got into LMU and Chapman
those are the three colleges I got in
because my grades you know they weren't
that great but you know i'd i was really
spending so much time doing all this
filmmaking stuff that I was so not
interested in whatever book report on
you know yeah so how did so how does
this get to YouTube connect those dots
for us so yet to kind of like throw a
stone in a pond and skip through a lot
of this basically I was one of the first
people that was a part of the station
you know that YouTube channel station
yeah I was a behind-the-scenes person I
was I got hired on by those guys to help
direct and write and produce so did
Danny yeah I got hired by Danny okay and
Lisa and Ben who did you know I knew
lisanova
from the YouTube live I spent time with
her there okay so with Tay Zonday
flash-forward you know two years or a
year and a half
once stations over now its maker people
are trying to make videos
this guy Glasgow Phillips who used to be
a writer on South Park that they brought
in to help write sketches and funny
things just kind of come up with funny
stuff he was hanging around and he used
like you know someone's got to do a
movie with all these youtubers someone's
got to do something and I was like yeah
I know I want to do it we're just doing
shorts I want to do a movie we got to do
this thing
and so he had had he had this idea of
doing a this horror film and using
chatroulette at the time it was a big
thing I didn't even know chat where that
was around back then yeah it was around
I came out and like what 2010-11 Oh
cousin ten knows 2010 I think is that
what it hit that was like that was the
summer I deal okay so build a movie
around something like that he was like
that would be so cool to do like a you
know horror movie like where this
killers you know showing up behind
people in a chatroulette
and it was random so you don't know
who that person is and that sounds like
a scary premise like yeah it's good and
so he's like okay so he went away and
just wrote this whole movie and it was
just like a it was like a conversation
it was very conversational at first and
then he came back and he was just like I
got your movie script here you go and he
just sent me this movie script and it
was like oh my god this is amazing
and then so I collaborate I started
collaborating with them he wrote the
first draft and then after that we
started Co wrote it together like we
started coming up with more specific
bits too because I mean he turned the
script out and a couple weeks and he was
you know he was quite the writer and so
then it became this long process of you
know developing this project while doing
totally sketch and then you know trying
to raise money for it and we tried to do
the traditional route you know it took
to some studios and got formal meetings
and had really fancy water and Fleming
just lovely and but you know people
didn't want you know at that time they
weren't ready to take a chance and say
oh I don't know if he's youtubers or you
know a big deal I don't know if they're
gonna translate to a movie and what
talent was attached at first I imagined
no one no one was touched okay mwah so
you were self and while you weren't you
weren't able to throw around a Shane
Dawson or a lisanova of DeFranco or
anybody like that wasn't wasn't involved
early on I just I told them that there I
was excited I didn't want to just attach
people and just and get people's hopes
up because that's the other thing like I
really I don't like to tell people
something until it's real so I'm never
gonna say hey I got this great project
rhettandlink let's do this thing and
then five years later I'm like we're
gonna get the money he's gonna have it
we're gonna get you guys back at TV and
it's like no I would never do that
I would come to you and say this is real
so I like to be that kind of guy so I
didn't really approach people but I had
worked like Shane had you know said
Michael you don't want to work with you
from doing all the mistaken do so we
became friends and so I would direct a
lot of videos for his channel and I
became a director for a lot of other
people's channel in addition to my own
so I was known as like hey if you're a
talent you need a director just call me
up and I'll come and I'll whip you up a
video and so that I kind of got that
reputation so I had sort of worked with
enough youtubers where I kind of got
like okay Shane he's a great actor like
he does this crazy comedy but he can do
anything
and I got that intention and hearing him
talk I knew that he wanted to do more so
there were certain people that I was
friends with that I was working with
that I got the sense that there's more
to them than what they're just showing
on YouTube and that if I have the right
opportunity with this film we're gonna
pull the trigger and we're gonna do
something great but how much money did
you need to get that was the thing it
was like we trying to raise money and
just you know sell it and do a studio
thing and for you know six months and it
wasn't going well and I was getting so
antsy because we were working on the
movie and I said you know screw it I'm
gonna put in my own money
and we're gonna make this thing and I do
not have a lot of money guys so who we
got to figure this thing out so we put
it together and basically we did this
movie for $200,000 so that that's I was
like every penny I had I was like um
this is all I've saved up is everything
everything I made from directing first
that's quite a nest egg for you to have
that sitting around that's yeah and then
to be willing to put it all in on this
one project with all the chips on read
well and and again back to the genre
switch to say okay I'm gonna put this
nest egg into something that is not kind
of what you were raised on and what you
had been working on to say okay I'm
gonna do this genre film or like how did
you make the transition like when you
first read that script were you like
because I know like for the scripts that
the few scripts full features that I've
read I can read a comedy and I'm like I
know when something's funny we read a
drama sometimes anyway I don't know if
this is good or not it's like I can't I
don't know if this is dramatic right now
right exactly you know because I know
comedy so when you read the horror genre
know if this is scary yeah I don't know
what kind of music should be for this
part I don't know I think I just because
I I was so into filmmaking at that time
to me it was like I didn't matter what
genre I just want I was so hungry I got
to make a movie like I just it was in my
blood I was like I gotta do it and just
doing all these shorts you know I love
doing shorts but I was just like
something I'd always wanted to do it was
making a film and so whether it was a
horror dramatic movie or you know comedy
it didn't
or musical I would have done anything at
that moment so this script came along I
saw that it could be done on a low
enough budget and I loved I actually
love horror movies so and and I love him
in a way that I'm not like where I'm
like yeah I want to see blood and don't
see the chainsaw cut the girl's head off
I'm like not that guy
you know there's some horror fans that's
all they want to see they just wanna see
yeah they're like gore fiends and I'm
not you know that's not me I like you
know I like the older stuff like
Rosemary's Baby is shining or you know
repulsion like I like all the Roman
plants he old horror movies are so scary
even the tenant it's like if you ever
watched that it's the scariest movie
ever you let it let's literally about a
man going crazy in an apartment after
this woman went crazy there and all of a
sudden he's just like dressing like this
woman at the end of the movie he like
throwing himself out of window just see
your mind melts when you watch that
movie it's like why is this happening so
you in a nightmare so you weren't just a
comedy guy and you were so hungry to
make a movie that this was gonna happen
it was gonna there was no doubt in your
mind just kind of like just Shauna not
Marshall hey I got the opportunity got
the public really yeah exactly like it
didn't matter what it was
I've sort of I've tried to be open to
the things that come my way I have this
feeling that I couldn't universe opens
up and like sends you something there's
a reason you know and maybe the reason
is to say no but for the most part most
things that come my way I find out I
find it in like I look at it and I say
oh like that I know how to do that right
maybe if I don't know how to do that
right away I get interested in the idea
of that I want to figure this out how
can this be done and so you you put the
money in put the money and uh you start
organizing the production yep yeah I got
this producer Michael Warren xur who had
done some you know he had done movies in
that budget range before and he had knew
he knew where we needed to spend the
money and where we could get away with
not spending the money because most
movies you know a good one you spend
some bucks on yeah unless you do it
really like strip down where it's found
footage you know and it's just you know
you're HVX and but like I said well film
to that to yours typically just to give
people a point of reference what the
budget would be I'd say three to five
million okay yeah that's what I've been
told from
watching the movie what most people
would spend on a movie like that it's
you know three to five million and so it
was something that it was you know an
exciting challenge and I love a
challenge now we I I have not seen the
movie oh I have seen the trailer and
based on the trailer I ain't seeing your
movie I mean I'm not gonna you know and
I'm not gonna apologize for that cuz I
know like it is scary movie really Oh
fun I like you know thing but I don't
like scary movies I don't care if you've
made it called smiley
do you happy that scared evidently you
spent a majority of the budget on making
that mask scary so how did you make this
mask I would make the mask well or you
kind of tell me how you made it the
moment oh it's not real yeah no it looks
scary as all get-out if I tell you
enough about the making of it you'll
right I can watch it yeah red boxes
yeah no it's and I hope you're not
offended but not honest my mom hasn't
seen I'm scared
no I you know I I totally understand in
a way I haven't seen the movie if you
notice but the the mask was something
that I don't know I'm just a sick person
I guess but I had this when we were
coming with the idea originally it
wasn't like a supernatural creature
thing it was more of a guy with a
stocking over his face who sort of
painted on with like lipstick or a red
marker he'd painted on like X's or a
smiley face or something like that and I
just didn't think like oh that's not a
you go see that movie I'm not scared
that's a guy in a stocking yeah right he
got a panty on his head you know so I
don't know I don't know what it was was
somewhere in the time where I was
developing with class go that I had this
vision of like oh well what if it's like
a skinned face and it's a stitched in
smile and the smile looks like an
emoticon you know I know some reason
that came into my head and then I drew
it and I started drawing and I'm showed
to people and I did a mock-up in
Photoshop and I showed you people and
they would freak out and I'm like this
is it
we got something I knew I was like if I
can literally show a photoshopped
picture on my phone to someone and have
a
I'd have him cower in fear and literally
shout and scream obscenities in public I
knew I was onto something so but it
wasn't made how was it made it was a
cover an actual man's face it was
actually the butt of a man took the but
we didn't enough skin as a consultant I
said you need to get the butt of a man
you don't remember walking funny
I got carry a big wallet now got it even
everything yeah because it was just one
but one side when she no so no so we
hired a you know a special-effects
makeup team who did our makeup for the
whole movie and you know we did I show
them the mock-up that I had and they
kind of helped to figure out how the
heck to make this thing and what we did
was we got the actor who's gonna play
smile he's got a Michael trimmer who's a
great actor very selfless because he had
to wear this mask where you really
couldn't see and you really couldn't
breathe in this thing because the eyes
were not lined up with human eyes they
were too close and the everything was
stitched up so well that you could
barely breathe and barely see so he's
running around he's like Ray Charles
like he does not know where he is at any
moment we ain't he's a talented musician
he's a very talented black musician no
he was no he's a great guy and what we'd
have to do is set him up on a path and
say okay you got about 50 yards you're
gonna be chasing a girl you got a knife
in your hand in action good luck god
bless no he was a super sport but we had
to mold his face get a mold of his face
and then they created this foam this
foam latex mask over over his face like
they did the molding and they they
created this great mass this guy George
Costanza and Greg mcdougal they they
just did it in their space in the valley
George Costanza yeah really yeah I don't
know I care a character could actually
have a real life
position that's interesting yeah okay so
that it's one feet to make a movie for
$200,000 I'm sorry did I say George
could say I meant Steve Costanza oh no
I've been watching Seinfeld
yeah I was like George okay George
Costanza so that's quite an
accomplishment making a movie for that
budget but then you you accomplish
something that very few people who do
low-budget movies accomplish you
actually got theatrical distribution
how did that happen did yes how did that
happen basically made the movie put the
trailer on the youtubes it because it
had mr. Shane Dawson mr. Toby Turner mr.
DeStorm power and totally sketch we all
talked about it the first week that the
trailer when a key is in it right Nikki
limo Steve green yeah Jason Horton bree
essrig Shana Malcolm I'm leaving out
somebody Richard Ryan I can hear my
heartbeat yeah
Elaine yeah so everybody's in it and and
everybody pushed to it the first week
from their YouTube channels they all
talked about it or they had a link in
their annotations to say hey we're in a
movie check out the trailer and so in
the first three days it got a million
views got on a home page it just started
like it was a snowball effect
and once it kind of took off and I
remember that it just I took notice then
yeah yeah it just kind of kept going it
was weird after that first week it
literally would get a hundred thousand
views a day in a $200 and as you know as
an observer it was okay youtubers in a
movie okay yeah roll the eyes I know
what this is about to be and then I'm
then I watched it and it's like whoa
there's that dude who's the actor who I
recognized on a lot of stuff with the
voice and he's awesome and whoa did you
see that I hope that mask is not real a
real project but I'm not watching this
movie this is for reals and it so it you
know so you're saying you got all these
views you got all this buzz Wow million
in a week kind of a thing yeah and it
but it wasn't you know that that was
just marketing but that the trailer as a
product was impressive and still is
thank you now yeah I think the I think
the internet kind of cocked it's headed
to the side and said what is this thing
because there's all these youtubers in
it
totally sketches channel who does comedy
and there's real actors in there and is
this a parody is this a real movie it
seems real but when's it coming out and
it's just like what just there's so many
questions and what was your what was
your answer to those questions at the
time what was the point I do silence no
I you know at that time we were still we
had just shot that we shot the film in
2011 this summer and put that trailer
out in November 2011 and just said I
knew it was gonna come out next year I
thought I was gonna be out by the summer
or something but we were still editing
we didn't even have the finished movie
yeah and we're just like let's put the
trailer out and see what happens was
worse than gonna happen right the worst
thing happens nobody likes it okay we'll
fix it later and it'll just nobody'll
know but it just kind of took off and
then it became this weird sort of urban
legend thing that people were wondering
what it was and it was getting passed
around so it it kind of caught us off
guard and it changed our whole
perspective because originally I knew
the very minimum I could make this movie
release it like say on iTunes and you
know just kind of put it on a website
for five bucks to do a louis c.k kind of
thing and just give it to the people and
just say here you go here's a movie I
knew that we could just do that and that
there would be some people that would
want to watch it just because of you
know it's so weird and random there's
you know some people in it that you'd
watch on YouTube so I knew at the very
minimum I could do that but once this
trailer took off we just started getting
all this interest from people in
Hollywood and so we started doing all
these meetings all these big studios
when we just had the trailer and we were
editing the movie and they were like we
want to see this movie we want to
distribute this movie we like met with
you know paramount and relativity and
all these big studios that were very
interested and they we were like oh my
god would make a good movie better like
now the pressures odd like all of a
sudden we had this pressure we didn't
realize like oh my god now we gotta make
this thing actually good and so during
that process we would edit it and put it
together and what we'd find is we show
to the studios and they really liked it
like we had these great meetings and
like they had four five screenings at
Paramount like they just kept wanting to
see it more they got more and more
people to come see it each time and the
final consensus for them was you know if
you you know it's sort of in the middle
between a 20 million dollar movie and
like a you know 1 million dollar movie
and we don't release movies that don't
look like 20 million dollar movies and
then we just don't have that in our
system and we're just like oh it's like
but we like it we really like it we see
all the potential we see everything but
yeah we just don't have that system set
up so it was just like this weird thing
where it was like oh that's flattering
but oh you're not gonna release a movie
ok so then we kind of had that
experience with a few different studios
and then we realize like oh well there's
interest but nobody wants to pull the
trigger so let's just do it the same way
that we made the movie where I just
funded it where let's let's just try and
get it in theaters ourselves let's just
do that so we went to AMC directly we
don't want to see theaters and they had
this program called AMC independent I
still have it where basically they will
if they like the movie they'll
distribute it in their theaters for free
but you have to bring people you have to
bring the you have to pay for the
marketing and you have to handle all the
stuff deliver the movie but they will
give you the theater space and they'll
split the profits of whatever you make
in the movie theater for you know and
how many screens are we talking about we
did 28 20 screens yeah so that was all
over the u.s. so okay all over major
cities that kind of thing mm-hmm
and so we we went in and showed them the
movie and they loved it and it was
literally like we had all these meetings
at all these studios it took months it
was just like months of meetings and
meetings we did one meeting with AMC
they watched the movie the next time and
they said how many theaters you guys
want and it was literally just like what
and they just they were in they were
just in on deal they were like we want
this we want to put it out so then it
was like yeah okay well we wanted out in
October 1 October 11 yeah let's do that
and like okay great and then it was like
oh my god that's some four months we
have to tell everybody about this movie
and so then we did our darndest to do
this marketing push to try and get the
word out with like no budget to to tell
people about this movie which I highly
advise to have some money if you're
going to put a movie in theaters to tell
people about it because it's very
expensive now and at some point
throughout this process I don't know if
this was after the release or during the
ramp up to it there was a situation
where
of a sudden a lot of personal
information from people involved in the
film including you was put out there
online and death threats death threats
after ends give us the download on that
tell us what happened with that god I'm
just reliving it's like I begin smiling
so yes so what happened was is this the
type of thing that like you've moved on
and like oh I've got to re-access this
this this is a painful part of my life
kind of thing no it's uh yeah I mean
because smiley in general was like you
know two and a half years of my life
like it was such a big part of just it
was like birthing this thing yeah like
having a two is like being pregnant for
two years and then like having been
raising like leaving the baby like
teaching the baby how to crawl and then
kind of abandoning it after that it's a
weird process but no it's not painful to
talk about but basically what happened
was in the film we talked about 4chan we
talked about the dark side of the
internet and some of the people that do
bad things cuz you know one of the
things that's it's in the movies you
know this idea that this theme of
cyberbullying and we sort of take it to
the extreme in the horror movie sense of
what happens if some someone is cyber
bullied to the nth degree and and so we
kind of took some real life things like
4chan and Anonymous and in certain
groups and and talked about them and
some of the characters in the movie have
opinions about these groups and so once
the word got out from like some early
screenings we did some screens for press
I think someone like a blogger or
something who was you know it would post
on 4chan they got really upset about how
we talked about a movie and like
explained all the scenes that we talked
about online and then for chant like
revolted against the movie and did like
what they call a raid where they got all
our information really attacked at me in
my family but they came after the cast
accrue me like my my parents my cousins
like just you know they like made death
threats to my dog it was very what way
well in the way that they got my phone
number they got my address they would
send things they called like non-stop
text messages they'd like saying that
they're gonna kill me they're gonna
murder me
you know everyone's gonna die you know
that kind of fun stuff it's like you'll
never see your family again just a lot
of that like it's just basically like 12
year old kids just pranking but they
just have a you know more sick sense of
humor than say the three of us and you
know that I mean you're familiar enough
with the Internet to know that I know
their children what it is but at the
same time it only takes one exact person
to be to act on do you know there's yep
there's this it's scary
well the at the same time the the
shooting that happened in the movie
theater was pretty recent at the Dark
Knight you know like there was that
whole new shooting that happened at Dark
Knight Rises screen I think it was thing
it was around that day yeah and so there
was like I everyone was kind of you know
there were like some people out there
doing some crazy things and so I was
trying to explain to everybody who was
getting attacked like these are kids
like this is not a big deal like this is
in some ways it's kind of funny but
nobody took it funny other than feet I
think just cuz I had said it spent so
much time on the Internet I kind of had
a better idea of what 4chan was and if
they're more about just like you know
screwing with people and just like
having fun just like they you know in
the movie we talked about like I did it
for the lulz like doing things for
laughs and kind of a sadistic way and
that's what they're doing they're just
like death giving a death threat to
someone is something really casual they
do it every day and so I didn't I wasn't
really really worried for my life but my
girlfriend was my parents a family like
the Casta crew everybody freaked out and
it was it was really a weird thing cuz
we had all these plans to do Q&A zand
meetups at lots of theaters and and make
it a vent you know make this thing like
a really come out and see the movie meet
with us and hang out and we'll have a
great time but then AMC got word you
know worried that someone might die as
one of the screenings of smiley which
would be terrible and so just kind of
you know it was a weird time it happened
two weeks right before the movies coming
out and this is the time where I'm you
know struggling to you know get
billboards in Times Square and all these
places for like no money like just try
to pull favors but in an ironic sense I
mean we saw the report on the Today Show
you all of a sudden you get a national
audience where you can sit down
it was Shane and kind of answer some
questions about it so I mean no one
wants to go through death threats to get
to that point but did it end up
ultimately raising the profile of the
film well it was a bummer because you
know like in releasing a film of someone
I learned that so much of it comes from
your PR company and having a good
company that can get you on the right
you know having a publicist that can get
you on the right talk shows and the
right interviews and all that and once
this story changed and it became a news
story they couldn't go and get the same
kind of entertainment like we couldn't
get Shane on like say Jimmy Kimmel
because it was a new store it was too
like serious but a mix and match a
serious news story with hey come see my
movie you know hobnobbing with Jimmy
Kimmel it was like a weird messaging
thing and they couldn't do both and so
once we started talking about as a news
story all of a sudden we couldn't be you
know treated in the same way that like
most movies get released where you go on
talk shows and do a lot of interviews
and all that it was just kind of stilted
so it was you know I think it helped in
a way cuz it created a mystique of like
oh this is a really dangerous movie
I just became like you know and this was
kind of dark way it's like it's like
forbidden fruit you know you know but in
the same way like we couldn't really get
out there in the traditional way and
just you know tell people about the
movie cuz like every other movie comes
out you get a blitz of publicity you
know for weeks the few weeks leading up
go see the movie go see the movie go see
the movie so hopefully people go see it
so that was the you know that was a
tricky thing I wish in hindsight that
you know maybe 4chan was a little nicer
to us right I got out well how did it do
you know did you did you make that
investment back or oh yeah baby
I drove I came here in a helicopter no I
you know I made the money back but you
know it was a combination wasn't just
the movie you know what it made in the
movie theaters I think it was a slow
process of you know having come out in
different countries and hadn't come out
on Showtime and Redbox and you know
Netflix and all these things right
you've already really you're one of the
first I mean I think it's pretty awesome
to say I'm one of the first guys that
came out through YouTube and made a
feature film you know it's it you know
now it's we've got camp Takota julian
smith earlier this year all near
biscuits announced that he was gonna
start working on the film i can't wait
for that and i you know and we can't
either
and we don't have any specific things in
the works but we aspire to make feature
films i think that this is a really
exciting time where do you think do you
think this is gonna become a thing it's
just like yeah people who come up
through YouTube who have an audience
they're gonna start distributing feature
films amongst our audience and do you
think there's more to follow oh yeah I
would hope so I think you know it's like
it's just more of a good thing it's like
you know rhett and Link you guys make
amazing videos to think that oh you guys
would have a rhett and Link movie that
sounds incredible you know if I'm a fan
of you guys I want to watch your movie
I'm pay a million dollars to watch that
movie per person per person let's take a
down payment to Nick need three people
to watch it and you're good for life
yeah yeah just increase the ticket price
ya know so I'm I'm super excited about
the prospects of that and you know and
it's weird because you know when the
movie when smiley came out I was
actually 23 when I made it I was 22 yeah
I was 22 years old when I made this
movie I thought of it and helped write
it when I was 21 so I was so young and I
made it and then and then it released
the year released when I was 23 but I
was turning 24 in December so I'm coming
up oh my god you know people get my date
wrong or whatever I am so it's like I
was so young when I made that I'm so
excited to just like keep making things
yeah keep it all going get the train
going you know but you know that just
takes way longer than a YouTube video
that's the only thing so hopefully we'll
see a ton of them a ton of good
interesting movies different movies to
like that's the cool thing about camp
Takota
so different in a way than what you see
from Grace or Hannah Hart or her memory
from their channels right well it's been
a pleasure having you we're looking
forward to the next project the next
YouTube video in the next feature film
thanks guys can't wait to see your movie
[Music]
and there it was our ear biscuit with
Michael Gallagher of totally sketch and
that's his Twitter handle let him know
what you think about his ear biscuit
twitter.com slash totally sketch one of
the things that really struck me from
his story was how obviously starting
such a young age getting director gigs
at like 14 years old directing
commercials and casting actors by cold
calling them and using a resonant voice
you know where he talks about going into
the bathroom and like splash and cold
water on his face and saying okay you
can you can do this you need to put your
game face on and then he comes back out
and he just does it you know this
there's a level of confidence required
to make it an entertainment that is at
times you just have to you have to
conjure it or even fake it to say oh
yeah I can do this I don't feel like I
can do it but I'm gonna act on the bit
of confidence that I have and I'm gonna
figure it out and that creates more
confidence I'm gonna be the
fifteen-year-old kid directing sha-na-na
I mean that's a just that's a phenomenal
story I mean he is a he's not a dramatic
guy you know he doesn't sensationalize
things so I think it can be easy to miss
the significance of some of those
details of his story that he got started
at such an early age he did these things
is such a young guy and that's what
translates into being potentially the
first youtuber to have a have a
theatrically released movie well I think
a lot of people me being one of those by
the way not knowing you know we've met
Michael and we were familiar with this
work but we didn't know him too well and
I didn't know him well enough to know
the behind the scenes of that was all
new information to me like how that got
made yeah and I think you know you see
the trailer and you're like okay yes you
know some somebody at some movie studio
somewhere thought it would be a good
idea to put a bunch of youtubers in a
movie to kind of get people to go watch
it and they got it an actor here an
actor there and they put their money
behind it I think that's how
I always assumed it came together
especially because of the timing of it
being 2012 which is still really early
in the process of translating a youtuber
into something like that but to know
that it was just he and another guy his
tenacity at every turn even you know his
own money right yeah and it's a note
we're gonna make this happen it's pretty
inspirational get it in theatres after
going through all those meetings say you
know what I'm just gonna we're just
gonna do this we're gonna find another
way it's it's a great story
does it make you want to make a horror
movie because that's what I hear that's
what I hear in your voice it makes me
want to make a movie I mean we already
have that desire but it you know what
I'm saying it fuels the fire but not a
hormone but no let's do one with a skin
face and you know no no how about just a
face on a butt no I mean we can just use
my face how's that okay well that's if
it you know you could say it might be
scary in your face
we'll also use your face and it's not a
horror it's not a horror no it's an epic
adventure yeah unless there's a music
dramatic it's dramatic it's dramatic
there will be tears shed we will be the
two of us we'll be crying throughout and
probably muddy we should be muddy at
some point you know what we should do
would you just be Lewis and Clark really
we got to get a second Julia do they
both make it because hopefully not
hopefully they both die because no don't
don't spoil it don't spoil the movie
that we haven't come up with yet okay I
guess you kind of have to spoil it in
order for us to come up with it but
we're not gonna share that with you but
we are gonna thank you for listening
I'm sure if you have ideas for a movie
you'll let us know please with her in
Facebook and you know we will read we
will just pour over your ideas for what
movie we should make and let us know
what you think about ear biscuits you
know it helps us a lot when you leave a
review and a rating on iTunes when you
leave us a comment on soundcloud
it also helps our show when you support
our sponsor Squarespace everything you
need to create an exceptional website is
right at Squarespace remember for a free
trial and 10% off your first purchase go
to Squarespace calm and use offer code
our and
our aandl thanks to Squarespace and
thanks to you for taking this biscuit
and just munching on it with your ears
question mark
[Music]
[Music]